hey guys it's football team from August
my name is just McDonald and the show
you're watching is called games for new
Microsoft has said today that the games
industry needs new and better ways of
making money Phil Spencer told game
informer that where movies and TV have
been able to monetize their back
catalogues quite well through meta
subscription services like Netflix
gaming has been unable to do the same
Spencer said that Triple A games are
high risk and he's a fan of what EA are
trying to do with their
subscription-based EA access program in
an attempt to monetize their catalog
nonetheless he thinks it's going to be a
hard road explaining frankly EA access
is going to be one of those things the
industry is going to learn from Sony
seem to have shut down microsoft today
by saying they don't feel the need to go
out and buy exclusivity in the same way
Microsoft are done with rise of the Tomb
Raider PlayStation EU boss jim ryan told
CVG that sony has a very powerful and
large network of studios who make
exclusive games for playstation he also
mentioned that partnering made sense for
the company with instances such as
securing Activision's destiny earlier
and with a handful of perks for gamers
speaking about Sony's gamescom press
conference ryan said you sold it before
the media briefing we showed updated
videos of games that we had revealed at
e3 that's because we wanted to keep the
show itself full of new fresh things we
think that gave us a good strong
convincing portfolio of exclusive stuff
and we're happy with that if you've had
your eye on GTA 5's upcoming appearances
on ps4 and xbox one you'll be happy to
hear that it's apparently going to be
mind-blowing that's according to Strauss
Zelnick CEO of take to parent company of
Rockstar Games Zelnick favorably
described rockstar to MTV saying they
want to blow consumers away whatever the
expectation is they want to exceed it
when you see GTA 5 on next-gen I want
you to tell me whether it is or isn't
better than your expectation I can
guarantee it will be better that I
include guarantee aside Zelnick also
shot his expectations for GTA 5 sales
sky-high
saying one way to look at it is that 34
million copies have been sold but at
seven billion people on earth so we have
over 6.9 million people left to address
that may well take out our award for
most overly ambitious quote of the week
GTA 5 doesn't yet have a specific
release date for pc ps4 or xbox one but
it's expected to head to shelves this
fall as for your question of the day let
me know whether you're going to be
picking up GTA 5 on new generation
consoles for the second or first time
that's it for me today I got one more
sure left tomorrow before I take a
holiday for a week so be sure you join
me for that one